[Music]
let me welcome you into the sick session
in this series philosophers in the midst
of history we're in the second year now
and we look at important philosophers
although importance is somewhat of a
relative term and their work in the
context of their historical situation
the person that I picked out for this
time as a medieval philosopher although
we'll talk about why that doesn't quite
fit in some respects is boëthius who has
a very long Latin name and part because
he was a patrician angeas manliest
submarino's Boethius we'll just calm
Alethea's he lived between 480 and about
524 525 so he died fairly young and died
in pretty gruesome way that we'll
discuss he wound up on the wrong side of
a power conflict and that brings in the
other guy who talked about a king a
barbarian king you could say Theodoric
and we'll also talk about you know how
these guys are ushering us into the
Middle Ages I'll make a few preliminary
remarks about the weed gifts and then
I've got some some things to say and it
places him in his historical situation
bold at the time and you know looking a
little bit at what happens after him and
a little bit before him and then I want
to talk about his his works his written
works and their importance of their
influence through the Middle Ages and
that means a bit you know into thinking
about what into the Middle Ages
something that we often take for granted
I'll tell you this the people who were
living in the Middle Ages sure didn't
think that they were the Middle Ages
because in order to same Italy you need
a point of comparison right so we'll
talk about some of those interesting
issues and then one of his books on the
consolation of philosophy is the penguin
version which is a very nice pitch
you know the Wheel of Fortune swinging
around it really did swing around for
this poor guy goofiest unfortunately an
lady philosophy consoling the weakest
who's kind of down in the dumps talk
about why that's the case I wanted to
talk about some of the key themes of
that work because it's probably his most
influential work and arguably his best
now we've got some time for Q&A at the
end but I always encourage people if
there's something that's not clear you
want to know more about it or you want
to make a comment or anything along
those lines just you know don't don't
wait until then just ask away or or say
what you have to say and yeah I think
that if you haven't read in before this
really is a great book to read it's one
of those that you often see you know if
you know those those great books
collections that you can get you'll find
this usually in those and I keep this
when I teach intro to philosophy classes
and sometimes when I teach ethics
classes because it hands a lot to say
and I think once the students get beyond
some of the translators have a bit of
you know V and Valley can addiction to
it once we get the Adam to see that the
issues that boethius was struggling with
our things that we still grapple with
quite a lot today
if solution to them is probably not one
that most people today would find
acceptable but it's interesting and so
we'll talk a bit about that so so
preliminary remarks first I me what you
can call a historian of ideas I am a
philosopher but much of what I do is
digging around in the history of
philosophy and getting to know some of
the thinkers really well by reading all
their works and then you know
occasionally seeing what other people
have to say about them and seeing where
they fit in relation to other people
and so when we think about Boethius in
that way he is a finger of major
importance what makes them so important
it's not just that he has some really
interesting ideas that are interesting
for their own sake out of context you
might say but it's also that he
influenced so many other people coming
after him particularly in what we call
the Middle Ages and we'll see why that's
the case now we place him in the
medieval period as an early as an early
medieval he would not have thought of
himself that way as a matter of fact if
we were going to ask him you know if we
understood you know ancient medieval
modern he would think it was an ancient
and that he was keeping ancient learning
alive
he isn't what we might call the twilight
of integrity you know and it's it's not
just the twilight when things are just
starting to get dark it's you know we've
got a nice perk out here and I think a
lot of us remember playing in the park
and feel like it's really dark and you
can't really see much in front of your
ear your face and you might stumble it's
close to that not quite there is that
quite the dark ages but it's getting the
first of the dark ages but it's getting
close to it a few other people who you
might know who are not all
contemporaries but are close in time and
are of similar importance for them the
development of the West would be the
monk John Cassian who lived from 362 to
435 st. Augustine of Hippo 3 you know 54
to 430 so those are earlier than hinder
their part of the formation boethius
read them would be philetus is familiar
with the literature at this time
Benedict of Nursia
born around the same time as boethius
Benedict the founder of the an addictive
order was a great man
stick orders in the Middle Ages and
actually still today and then later on
Gregory the Great
the Pope who brought about all these
important reforms and wrote some
important works keys later out you'd be
five for you so easy after we thesis
death to 604 but these are all more or
less in the same period what would if we
have to say what is we is as real
importance for the history of ideas well
I mentioned you know the consolation
this book by itself given how
influential it turned out to be and how
many times it was copied and translated
would have been not to ensure in his
place in the history of ideas but he
also did a lot of other important stuff
and things you have to do with keeping
learning a lot you might actually
provide just like people talk today
about the Benedict option that's
actually something that's getting quite
a bit of interesting press in in some
conservative circles we might talk about
the believe theist option as well in
terms of how learning is is preserved
and passed on in an age which seems to
be chewing it up fairly quickly so what
we've used himself is a you know an
important thinker he traces up new paths
for Western philosophical and
theological but the culture that he
inhabits is is what we in history
classes talk about as after the fall of
Rome and in these barbarian successor
kingdoms it's not really understood at
the time that way Rome got sacked Rome
got taken but everybody at the time
still sees themselves as living within
essentially something like a continuing
Roman Empire and it's you might think of
it as a Roman Empire adapted to new
people new faces new situations or if
you as remember that bold line about you
know meet the new boss same as the old
there's a bit of a question kind of as
well in belief theists in his situation
and its fate as works I think what we
can see is an important juncture point
between the ancient period you know and
the coming medieval period so placing
him in his time in his historical
situation I give you a timeline it's not
meant to be you know comprehensive it's
just meant to give you some some ideas
about where things fit in and who's some
of the players in this art and also I
also give you a map that can be kind of
useful as well showing you know the
Barbarian kingdoms right the Ostrogoths
or actually just of the kingdom of the
east got here we caught that cooler
become Ostrogoths and Visigoths you know
and the vandals you know we vandals
today of something different
the names Custer do you guys have gained
through it and broke a lot of things and
then established other kingdoms kingdom
of the Franks you know of course in what
we now have as France and parts of
Germany and the Netherlands and then you
notice the eastern Roman Empire in which
you know present-day Greece and Turkey
and also controlling some of the other
parts of the Mediterranean as well so if
you look at this timeline you notice
that Louie theist is born into a time
that's seeing a lot of political hockey
and that's to play an important role in
in what's going on the Roman Empire by
this time has been divided into East and
West in part along linguistic lines
right the East was was Greek speaking in
some parts depending on how much the
Roman Empire actually controlling it
might also include some Romanian
speaking not a meaning sorry if our
meeting was great state waking it and
when I was when I want to say there in
Egypt was Coptic and then Aramaic in the
West it was lat
lavel is used and these are two
different administration
entities so you know you'd have an
emperor in the West and an emperor in
the heat and sometimes they got along
and sometimes they did doesn't sound
like a really great cricketer Bergen
Einstein great great frankly but it was
the best they had
if you think about the difficulties in
governing that much territory and you
know carrying out communications with
the technology that we have the time
it's you know pretty incredible that
they did as much as they they were able
to do so the woman that had been divided
into East and West there by that time
you know they had hundreds of years of
volts and civil wars and factions and
intrigues going on so that was kind of
par for the course they also did
centuries of fighting against the
barbarians and the barbarians this is
this is an idea that they kind of
inherit from from the Greeks barbarian
is actually a Greek word bomb ervil's
right and Latins take it over they also
you know call the they had the Greeks
didn't call themselves Greek to call
themselves colonics and the Romans
called them Greeks and it was kind of an
ethnic slur put down if you're lots of
their language sounds like and say they
were the bargain of the old explanation
for the barbarians they just sound like
there's a bar bar bar bar bar but you
and I can't understand these people
obviously they don't have feel Knology
and social skills and look at how they
live sort of that and to not like us
civilized people here who the conflict
you see in many cultures and the Romans
and then you know not just conquering
barbarians but assimilating for quite
some time so you know the Gauls great
example you know you read about Caesar
fighting the Gauls for the time that
we're talking about this the Gauls are
romanized they they have no interest
whatsoever in living like the people
outside of the Rome
Empire and you know reviving these you
know there's wonderful warrior days they
like things the way they are and they're
scared as hell about these Germans
coming in who now are the seeming tough
guys the Germans they don't know this
but the Germans are actually being
driven by people that they're scared of
the Huns and there's all these
migrations winging it but for for
several hundred years
you know the German the Germans had been
crossing the border and being
assimilated one way to use simulate
people is you offer them jobs so they
would they would make them into part of
the arm
Fedorov equals of a frame and they were
essentially sort of mercenaries that be
paid off here and there sometimes they'd
be more romanized sometimes less
and the Romans you know we're constantly
having to figure out how they are going
to manage this this vast empire against
the pressures of other people coming in
so by the time that believe Deus is on
the scene the Romans for example of
abandoned Britain when they abandoned
Britain they leave you know a whole
bunch of people have been romanized
they're the romanized Britons and you
know Angles Saxons are going to come in
and fight against them they you know
they're having a lot of pressures coming
from various driven tribes from Hans who
now are on the scene from a VARs over in
the east and certain Slavic groups as
well
Rome got sacked by by the Visigoths in
410 st. Augustine live to see that
thought that was pretty terrible it's
kind of you know that viewed as sort of
the end of the Western Roman Empire but
didn't have it to continue now because
just taking a city doesn't mean you
actually control the city or all the
things we have and the bar you know the
Germans tended to be attracted by the
culture that they saw themselves in the
Vandals invade Spain and North Africa
they sacked Rome again in 455
so you see you know sort of scattered
getting set up and Loan institutions are
surviving so it may surprise you to find
out that you know all web - Luisi is
aside there's still a roman senate they
don't do anything hope it's the king who
decides what's going to happen but there
is still time one way we know this is
weak this was a senator you know there's
still Roman consuls these are people
that are charged with you know
essentially representing the government
and people again not doing much within
the new administration
what they enroll we gives of the console
his sons were consuls his father with
the console and so these Roman
institutions are being we might say
repurposed the being adapted to the new
realities another big issue that's going
on at the time is in the Roman Empire it
become Christian and so you know one of
the things that happened if you remember
your church history and not everybody
saw eye to eye on this developing
religion and so there were a lot of what
from the vantage point of the present
you know we agree with Orthodox who the
one and called heresies most of the
heresies were pretty pretty strongly
against the Orthodox I don't want to you
know romanticize them or anything like
that but it doesn't that Worthen us were
always been so nuns they can find
heresies in each other there in Arizona
it's a wide range and what it was
complicated by the fact that you got a
couple different languages in place to
why she got Latin right and in the east
you get Greek and Aramaic and topic and
you know translating terms back and
forth theological terms can sometimes be
a bit tricky so you can't always do the
same thing in in each language but when
was it dominated dominated by
Christianity Oh Rome well so so yeah so
it starts there's a period of like
growth in persecution
the same time right just you know it
can't Constantine is the guy who
essentially makes it official and so you
know we're talking about you know fourth
century yeah and then not here's the
thing it's not as if you can change
these things overnight fifty-five you
know like it's imagine that we were
suddenly to impose a state religion here
in the United States many people go
crate together right all sorts of would
think there's riots now and if people go
nuts how many decades would it take to
actually get it established to the point
where you can rely on it doesn't happen
all at once it takes a while and so now
by the time that buoy theus is around
they've actually managed to go not just
through sort of christianization of the
empire but even you know one effort who
tried to turn it around and reintroduced
paganism it didn't work and then and
then it goes on from there now it's more
manner not as more a matter of well what
kind of Christianity what brand what
flavor you know what what do you
actually believe and one of the biggest
rivalries in a time weed is is between
the Aryans who believe that that Christ
was a really great guy but not you know
not a personal Trinity and the Orthodox
area ISM and one time actually sort of
occupy the central Seton and
Constantinople
it is this comes into play in part
because the guy we're going to talk
about Theodoric he was an area and the
Visigoths were for forty area I mean the
host your classwork and so you know
depending on where you sat you might you
might not like the other Christians
you know and then all of this often
times get wrapped up in politics too
because you know if you don't like the
guy over there and you want to take over
his territory it just so happens that
he's a the wrong interpretation of the
faith now you've got a great pretext to
go and start carving out so much as his
territory and you know vice versa when
it comes to boo India's themself we you
know we know a lot of things without you
we don't know exactly where they fit in
terms of dates we know a few of the
dates but we're just kind of guessing
where the others fit in so I didn't put
a lot of them into the kind of life
you'd born in Rome to a very old family
you know he's of the patrician class
which is a higher class it means
something it doesn't mean what it used
to mean
in ancient Rome they're no longer like
the ruling class but it's a prestige
sort of thing and his father died young
unfortunately but fortunately there's
another guy I'm seeing who adopts
leafiest takes him in handles his
schooling Samak assits his name and so
Marcus really values classical education
and literature he can read Greek Louis
is able to read Greek and a type and
fewer and fewer people aren't able to do
some of the west and the weakest really
likes this this guy eventually will
marry his daughter rusticana and have
two children one's named weakness one
was named Sobotka those are his two sons
so I have been a great family which is
good for him we don't really know where
he got his schooling
some scholars wanted to make you know
rather speculative claims if you like
much Alexandria which was a major center
for learning at the time were cath ins
but we don't really have any evidence
that that was the case you know he was
living at a time when books had not
yet he gotten to really disappear so you
know he talks about having a really well
stocked library and that was probably
the case so Marcus had probably gathered
together all these these books he
becomes involved in a couple different
directions one one direction is
political and the other direction is
scholarly so he's you know he's sort of
like a you know if you think about other
great thinkers like niccolò machiavelli
you know we know him for the prince
where he has a kind of real politic kind
of approach to things he also did
discourses on Libya where he's a little
bit you know less bullish on pure force
any rope you know he wrote a comedy and
some other things there was after he
left his DJ his day job he was an
administrator and boëthius was doing
things like this as well you see a lot
of people in history of thought doing
this before we go to universities and
you know we look for our philosophers or
theologians there a lot of people
actually have the where several
different hands and so that's what we
theists did so this is a good time to
talk about this Theodoric if you look at
the timeline you see Theodorus showing
up a little bit in the middle right so
first there's the things going on within
the Western Roman Empire this guy Nepos
has made the Western Roman Emperor by
Leo Leo is and heats traditionally the
Eastern Emperor is more is more
important than the Western so what sort
of like you know big brother little
brother
cancer Gino becomes Co ever with his son
Leo until Leo dives and then Zeno knows
the eastern after the sky arrestees who
is a military leader establishes of son
Romulus Augustus as the remember in the
West so nepos pleased
nasha vo himself has to flee from a plot
and revolt and now you get this guy
Otis Otis er is another German he shows
up almost some people think he might
have been of some alert some other group
and he'd opposes agasa vez he becomes
the king of it now you like to wait a
second where did the Emperor go well by
being king of Italy to use in effect the
Western Roman Emperor and he's getting
you know some support from the eastern
Roman Empire for a while he invades
Dalmatia kills off murders of Nepos and
then Zeno and the East declare decrees
the Western Roman Empire over so that
means that Otis er is really not a
temporary he's just sort of a you know
an administrative official is a
second-in-command the Western Roman
Empire is more or less done officially
that doesn't mean any of its
institutions going away and now what
happens Otis er gets talked into
favoring arrival to zero and invade the
eastern Roman Empire so Zeno you know
find them a lot and a little bit after
that they adore who himself is really
interesting guy he's a German he's a a
Nostra gap in Eastern God but he winds
up being a hostage which means the ends
up getting raised by the Eastern Romans
which means that he learns their ways
which means that he gets to study their
military tactics it was smart guy means
that he sees with good in their culture
and what he might think when he
eventually becomes king over his own
people in all ways
older men he has all this in the
background and he also knows how rich
Constantinople is so one of the things
we scraped like the bigness attack rich
cities essentially like a protection
racket you know we won't invade you what
are you going to give us and they would
buy them off with something and that's a
campus now this put the spark in the
mind of Xena
you think this guy could be very useful
we've got this guy go to serving he's
raising hell over the West I don't
really like what he's doing you Theodore
I could take care of that for me
he said you plant the suggestion why
don't you go over to Italy and it carob
Oh dessert for me so they do that
he takes the Ostrogoth and they conquer
Italy and now she becomes the king it
takes about three years but eventually
you know the last city Raveena
surrenders
you know Theodoric hold the banquets as
we're all going to be reconciled with
each other and at the banquet kills
Odinson which was nothing you know he
didn't come up with that there are
plenty of people who've done that before
him and you notice that I don't have too
much elves in there until later on but
one of the things that they had norick
was trying to do was put back together a
Western Roman Empire and he was doing it
by recognizing the realities of time so
you know the Ostrogoths controlled Italy
and you know some of the other area
around there the Vandals were in North
Africa the Visigoths are in Spain the
Franks are north
he starts marrying people and marrying
off as his family to establish a whole
network of connections because he wants
to establish his his you know his rule
and that of his family as essentially
like a new Roman Empire in the in the
West but now one that will unite these
these successor kingdoms and you can do
that in part of the Roman cultures still
there in North Africa
in Italy in what we call France golf you
know in parts of Germany in Spain so he
is you know see him doing this he
marries the sister of King Clovis of the
Franks he marries off his daughter to
this guy you ther it was his great hope
you Theron is from the Visigoths and he
apparently is really a guide but
unfortunately he dies young and what we
see in the happening is you know more
dynastic struggles in the West Indies
sorry and another thing that's important
as well
a little bit of church history there had
been something like a schism between
east and west
not a full schism like would later not
have and separated Catholics off from
the Bertha docks but enough that you
know it was it made it much more
comfortable for Theodoric get a lot more
freedom of action the churches got over
that and start to reconcile and you know
that this schism is end of the occasion
schism that sort of starts to put the
heat on Theodore and we see him moving
from a policy where he was an area but
the more or less let people believe what
they wanted to believe to starting to
enforce things starting to crack down we
theist looks like somebody who got
caught up in these various intentions
and cracked at what ends up leading to
believe his death is like I put here
this is this guy Cipriano's accuses the
ex-con soul of Venus of carry on a
treacherous correspondence with the
Eastern Emperor he's sending letters
back and forth right and so what would
this mean does it mean that the eastern
Roman Emperor would be sort of
reasserting his authority over the west
and Theodoric would be
going down in power what ends up
happening is disbelief theist jumps to
this guy's defense and says the charges
Cipriano's is false but if Alby if Alby
knows did this so also have I am a whole
Senate with one Accord done it it is
false he says it's to that they ignore
this sets the trap because now they
bring forth what look like false
witnesses to say oh no this really was
the case and believe just now has put
himself on the wrong side so he winds up
being accused of treason as well and
this his father a little bit later
called stepfather I father-in-law as
well and we Deus is arrested and he's
exile about 450 miles away from from his
home and put in this place he there for
about a year he writes the consolation
of philosophy there and then he is we
were not quite sure stabbed qualms it
did something pretty pretty bad to him
and that's it there's no real trial
there's it's just a safe so and he winds
up on the wrong side of history now if
there's a little bit of irony and that
Theodoric dies himself a little bit
after that and never accomplished the
things that he did you send us off to so
you know he allowed a good guy to die
for very little games and then it was a
great loss for atheist die for it so
this is a good transition to talking
about his works but before that any any
questions about through a lot of history
at you some of it's probably a little
confusing
well especially for treason and so will
trees it in walk late right so you know
sometimes we you know we charge people
for perjury will actually charge them
for the underlying offense
you know it's all Martha Stewart a bunch
of prison for example okay but we see it
says if this guy actually engaged in
treason and so did I and so did you know
the rest of the Senate
well the rezident Senate they're like
don't bring us into this but and so he
took a stand on principle and really for
the right side and wound up on the wrong
side and they bring forth these
witnesses they've been charging like
sorcery you know which that's that's
pretty far out of love with it because
it is right know could help I don't know
anyway you know gentlemen you're not on
principle well the other thing is if
they're in Kampen you know fifteen years
before it wouldn't occur because
Theodoric wasn't concerned at that time
about what was going on in the Eastern
Roman Empire this guy was being charged
for treason because he was kicked he was
supposed to be carrying our
correspondent to the Eastern Roman
Emperor and Dan Doric wanted to you know
consolidate his power in the West so you
know it really chopped up charges so was
it like a Billy Budd Oh tragic uh know
example you don't I mean well you can
see that the could guess to that but
then there'd be a lot of billy budds he
wasn't the only Billy Budd his
father-in-law is also executed if you
think about almost like a purge in some
respects I guess
and what would major advance well these
these these guys won't be you know
attempted to conspire with the Eastern
Roman a polluter who might have designed
you know power structure that Theodoric
had been building up all it was
facilitated by the fact that the two
churches now you know so you get the
easier in church and the Western Church
we're all part of one big church and
we're not the area but they don't they
don't
we get along with each other now there's
somebody reconcile so let's make a
political realignment in that respect
you know and there's that old you know
you know friend of my enemy and the
enemy of my enemy is my friend results
are a logic that says well whoever
spreads with my enemy
they're my enemy too and that looks to
be what Theodoric pursued yeah um so I'm
just trying to get a sense of like this
the general landscape yeah with a big
overview it sounds like there's like a
lot of little power struggles and I'm
but they're still sort of this pretense
of sort of Roman comes and I so I'm
wondering how but they're still like
slaves or like and and yeah what word
where the people still like soap recipe
we're not rising up with a justice sort
of upper classes that were trying to
seize power from each other
it was it was mostly non class works
well then if you know complicated by the
fact you get these German barbarians
coming in and becoming part of the rear
structure Theodoric actually didn't
allow intermarriage between Ostrogoths
and enrollments interestingly enough
yeah he was worried about the Roman
people in general both like upper-class
and ordinary people being against him in
one way or another because some of the
tentative to religious stuff he was a
human Arian the Ostrogoths her Arian
the Roman people were Catholic and so it
was always a bit worried about that we
this is from the Roman people such as
father Marcus you know the religion will
remind you at that point where they've
already for more in the East at that
point well it'll be a lot more people
are still living in Rome in Italy the
Ostrogoths just invaded the think of it
sort of like that imagine that we just
brought in a whole bunch of people here
we didn't take any
few people may have died because you
know we have accidents or something like
that we just plug a whole bunch of
people out of mainland China right down
here and back one and say all right
everybody get out of your work you know
except that the the Chinese also have a
guy they're all connected with and he's
the one in charge now
get above the rest of us would be like I
don't it's almost should be like I'm
learning Mandarin tomorrow because I
want to get a line and you know rise up
through the ranks some of those might be
like things are a lot better than what
they were here you know I wonder if
there's any way we can get at that you
think about it no it doesn't look like
it you know but you have to be somebody
like Theodoric would have to be careful
he just his brain was very do you know
so I imagine he probably felt threatened
yeah exactly were the area I would
before the aryans main quite insane well
so this guy area so he's a theology and
it's a designation for those who
followed his theology which there's more
to it than that's but essentially that
Jesus was not the second person the
Trinity is a really great guy but you
know it's just God the Father and Jesus
was some Hollywood used by hand or
adopted by there's very variation that
any of you think about it was kind of it
attracted a lot of upper-class
intellectuals throughout the Roman
Empire they were like this zones have
been more reasonable than this Trinity
stuff in some way it was some people
have likened it to the you know very
burly Unitarianism but it's very
different than what we think of as
Unitarianism today and that they didn't
be very peaceful and the areas in the
Roman Empire were quite often you know
very willing to engage in deadly power
politics with
not really so when everyone else started
returned the favor about the smell I
don't want to say if they were they were
more prone to that than others
what weight was burying around that's a
good question I think he's a third
century although I might be wrong
keeping all these things in my head is
done to the tricky I believe the
council's I see a Delta Area well sort
out the effect yeah I mean there's
there's dealing with like in the sense
of having a pronouncement and then
there's actually being able to enforce
it and that's been done and it is where
it come didn't that's done that having
somebody who's got political power of
being willing to back you up so if the
emperor suddenly becomes area you're
you're in trouble right or in the West
if this guy Theodore I think Marion he
is not gonna be enforcing it he's gonna
be doing the other way it looks like
toward the end of his reign the fact
that he died he he had some some purges
planned the Orthodox so let's talk about
about three pieces works and I'm not
gonna try to summarize all these you've
got a page that shows you what we've got
it and instead let me just talk about
these main categories so you notice that
he's got translations of other people's
works where we have said the project
which he didn't realize unfortunately of
translating all of Plato's works and all
of Aristotle's works into Latin can he
done some the Middle Ages would have
looked very different I think in terms
of intellectual life than they did
because most of Aristotle's works had to
wait until we got these translations
from from you know Spain from the Arabs
in the getting in the 12th century but
they didn't really get catch on in till
about the thirteenth century so this is
a long time the only platonic types
that they had last for one time with
conveyance which is a if you've ever
read it's really interesting dialogue
but it's not really that typical of
Plato's works the one that we often have
people read if we Diaz had succeeded we
would have public that had the symposium
we would have had all these other great
works but you see that he was able to
translate some things he also wrote
commentaries on those works some of
which we have some of which we don't
many wrote treatises of D acting other
people's works this is important you
know the the honorific and odd music
were used as textbooks throughout the
Middle Ages and they are a way to
preserve you know ancient learning this
guy who is essentially just adapting
nickel Marcus of your sorrows and
Aristotelian who also had a lot of neo
Pythagorean philosophy mixed into what
he was doing and so believed his texts
were you know sort of the cutting edge
at the time then original philosophical
and rhetorical or logical treatises you
notice he's got a lot of things there he
is thinking the the logical works of
Aristotle he's taking what he knows from
Plato from the neoplatonist
authors like porphyry he's also taking
what we had the stoic logic coming to us
from Cicero and also from from Seneca
not not logic so much for the video here
at Seneca and he's putting these
together and things that can be used as
also text books and engaging in some
speculation that will end up proving
useful for other people coming after him
and it's useful to remember at the time
too after him for for quite a while it's
not going to be a time of the original
thought it's going to be a time of just
like keeping stuff alive then and you
know teaching it and so he provides a
backbone for that a lot of these wind up
in the monasteries and then you notice
the last of them is this
halation philosophy which was its own
type of book he also wrote some
theological treatises he writes a book
on the Trinity which is indebted to st.
Augustine comes right out and says it
you know you write some other
interesting ones as well and you know
you can see them there he is engaging in
thought that can influence the emotions
in the Middle Ages so what I'd like to
say about this is I don't want to take
up too much time is these books like I
said would end up providing a portion of
the educational resources for learning
that's taking place in what was going to
be the Middle Ages at first this is in
monasteries and Cathedral schools
monasteries used to be that place to go
for an education right in fact some
people actually became monks to pursue
their education not because they
actually wanted to be monks and then you
know with the rise of the universities
boethius's works were used in scholastic
settings as well even when they are
surpassed they were being commented on
so he was one of the people who might
say set the agenda and then the
consolation this work had even more
influence not only was everybody in the
monasteries and schools reading it over
time benefactors was visible of the work
that you would find in most monasteries
it would be copied out it was also
translated fairly quickly into other
languages so for example a King Alfred
has it translated it's Old English it's
translated into old French Geoffrey
Chaucer translates it into Middle
English Queen Elizabeth has it
translated into really modern English I
gets translated into German hands wide
Providence I mean it's still also being
wrapped
in Latin but it becomes part of
vernacular literature as well it
influences Dante who brings up weakness
it influences trust or quite a bit and
here's a quote that I found by CS Lewis
which is kind of a interesting segue
into talking about the Middle Ages so
Lewis said to acquire a taste for this
book is almost to become naturalized in
the Middle Ages
now if you've read the book I think you
understand why after the themes that
he's talking about the drama all any of
the piety that's involved but we didn't
didn't consider himself a drug medieval
and so I think we have to ask this
question what actually are the Middle
Ages and we know what the African story
right so you got the ancient period and
let's say it ends at the sacking for
first second because Rome keeps getting
sacked don't vote for it over again
right let me have the Middle Ages and
you know we know they were there
they're kind of Dark Ages there are some
high points you know we have the rise of
courtly love and the universities and
they also the Crusades and all this
other stuff going on and you know what
would life life after most people is
pretty pretty bad I mean if you're a
Roman slave your life was probably about
as bad as you know somebody in the
Middle Ages was but there was there's a
lot more technology and you know more
culture in the ancient period another
Middle Ages they're kind of digging
themselves out of the fabric we've all
see the movements right everything is
brown you know separated night I know
most of that is actually nonsense the
Middle Ages were a time very different
experiences that people were having some
there are only some places rising in
some places falling there were great
cultural development a lot of
technological developments happening in
the in the Middle Ages
well usually representative
through dark period and then we get the
Renaissance right everything is reborn
and way is so wonderful and then you
know black death you know a hand in that
somewhere along the line it's actually
you know playing an important gold life
by making it harder to buy later so you
know working people prosperous improves
and then we get the modern appearing
right technology science you know the
Enlightenment all of this great stuff so
where does boots fit in well he's at the
very beginning of that medieval period
so he's at the time when antiquity is
lights have gone out and now it's
primarily just you know years of
darkness until July that's the story we
used to tell quite often if you look at
histories of philosophy they'll mention
Augustine iJustine was still enrollment
you know and then we have you know Louie
this and then it's like a big long
period until we get to you know SCOTUS
Iraheta and then he's you know just a
sir flash-in-the-pan
and it's not until we collect people you
know over a century later well know
there was there was quite a bit going on
but we you know the people who were
involved in that they still thought of
themselves and living out of this
magazine of ancient Roman culture they
didn't think of themselves as medieval
just thinking like I put it up to be
medieval means that you have to be at
the middle of something you'd have to
think of something else beyond that they
think of themselves is living in a
culture that in many respects is gone to
pot and they're not quite sure why and
they want to try to keep as much of it
alive and adapt themselves to new
circumstances and try to develop as much
as they can on that basis monasteries
later on you know it become owaisi's not
only of learning but also economic
development
you know administration of justice towns
would grow up around them because they
provided some sort of work the same
thing to be said about you know other
places of learning as well and boëthius
is going to play the role so India
medieval or not it really depends on how
we how we define our terms we we look at
it that way if you want to study him you
go to video philosophy better theology
classes but that's not how he would have
understood it at all I'm interested to
see before we talk about some of the key
themes of the consolation what you guys
make of that that's our training paints
on there edie notion I mean if you think
about it he's providing what he's
providing is some of his own stuff these
provided stuff from ancient culture and
that's how it survives in the period
that we call the medieval period at
least in the the West particularly in
the monasteries so the lantern there's
someone then he brought learning from
the old ages into a new ages well I mean
they were old ages to him right
Aristotle had been gone for a comment
his time into a new Khan
yeah although he he didn't see it course
yeah and I think he recognized that it
was important because fewer and fewer
people could read Greek right there more
people the west before who could
recreate it was kind of disappearing was
well aside the cultural decline right
that it was important to have Latin
translations and then he you know he
wrote commentaries and
other works in parks is that like and I
didn't either comment settings and make
it easier to understand or improve on on
these as well yeah I was just
my times are survey so when was when was
the library in Alexandria burned oh yeah
I don't know I want to say enough 300
right welcome 40 or I might little later
my own standard was instead of learning
for a long time I don't know I just
wondering how his viewpoint of that and
because that was a lot
oh so that goes with the important books
damn well yeah there were libraries
everywhere you know there's a question
whether you can use the word get to them
know you give them the read them so if
you could have a library of Greek works
say in the city of Rome and that would
be great
provided anybody could actually be Greek
but he could so for him he could have a
few other people yeah his father-in-law
hood but fewer and fewer people were
able to do that I mean just a few
centuries later you know the only people
reading Greek in the western part of
Christendom I use Irish monks you know
that's how quickly everything fell apart
so you know you can have a book like for
definitely ourselves categories so
here's those categories is that and
beginning it's kind of tough that it's
kind of a beginning work of logic right
and it's in Greek it's not written in
Latin and it would not be you could have
as many copies with you like floating
around but if nobody can actually read
it
inland it doesn't do anybody any good so
who did he who was his peers
I mean who did he discuss ideas with
well but we don't know much about that
we we know that his father-in-law was
somebody who is very close to presumably
he would have brought up his sons that
way as well his wife was supposed to be
pretty pretty not such a smart but
inclined towards learning if you must
have had some friends
yours interestingly there's a guy can't
you Doris who we know some things about
we theater Jim he winds up taking
Louise's place and the administration
after boethius is tried there you know
sentence for treating right Kasia Doris
them have any problem with the the
Ostrogoths and gets along with them just
just fine and presumably he was closer
but he doesn't take away his aside so
how close not that close
and he becomes somebody who can also
gets back there are some other people in
other places who are writing things data
again largely the monasteries that
preserve this stuff in that you know
offer to the what there is of an
intellectual public in the centuries to
come but they're writing in other parts
of the Empire they're not they're not
all in the same place so much is a bit
digression but if you think about what
it took to keep a book in circulation
any time it's not like you know we've
got paper which is really great to
happen prints of all those wonderful
technology you can to you know put it on
to other fabrics and you've got to get
to do if a hand and hopefully you have
somebody who could do it without making
mistakes because that's how you get you
know screwed up copies it was very
time-consuming and expensive to
reproduce books now please with leg
Alexandria they have the whole system
you know other places then other word on
commercial booksellers who you know
we do this in ancient Rome but as the
economy shrinks and things get more
inserting as we need more people for
doing things like agriculture you know
just maintaining existence there's less
and less people doing that so winds up
being primarily something later on in
the monasteries for another generations
so to want to keep learning alive is a
real investment of yourself sometimes
you can rip - well let's let's talk then
about this this great work the
consolation so how many of you have ever
had a chance to read it just one okay
sorry
this would be the if you only bring one
thing out of this lecture might be
impress on you that you should read this
book and that you will probably enjoy it
once you get past some of the
translators choices of diction some of
them can like I said be a little via
Valley so I mean if you're into that
sort of thing that's great but I'm not
so the translation of philosophy is in
five books essentially five chapters and
it's you notice like if I hold it up
here you see there's like smaller
columns and then bigger columns that's
cuz it's actually divided into poetry
and prose and it was this constant
rhythm poem about the subject matter and
some prose poetry than prose it's also a
dialogue if the dialogue between
boethius who is in his prison cell so
he's writing in a very Otto referential
lake I'm in my prison cell so writing
this book cuz you know it wasn't like
prison in other places they let a POW
feel patents and paper what's he's mecha
like a turnover the power structure that
way and this beautiful woman comes to
visit
and her name is philosophy and he knows
her because he you know was raised by
her and studied with her for years and
years and years but he's really down and
he's down because he was on top of
things
he was person who was in charge of you
essentially for like Theodoric's excel
you know the person who is making
everything happen she fell that far she
saw his sons attain offices he had a
wonderful family everything was going
good for him and then everything
suddenly went to crap and you know the
rest of us who never had anything like
that you know I think we can we can say
we might be a little bit more resilient
or not I don't know maybe maybe having a
great enjoying great opportunities and
stuff it doesn't make you less resilient
but there's certainly more to take away
you know and everything does it taste
like cause like he's upset does matter I
keep that upset he's depressed he's
crying he's having a terrible time
and so philosophy comes to him and the
whole structure of the book is
philosophy healing him healing him of
his sadness his pain but also of his
mistaken understanding of things and you
know you ever make a dumb decision in
your life that you've stuck with and
somebody came to you and you know
hopefully didn't slap you around but you
know shook you and said what the hell is
wrong with you you know and then you
know they sort of explained things to
you and after a while you got a better
perspective that's a philosophies doing
she's not doing it physically she's
doing with arguments and explaining
things and reminding him of things that
he learned at one time and saying here
is where the rubber meets the road you
know you said in the past that for
example a good person is going to do
well no matter where they are here's the
test buddy
because you're in a situation where all
of your you know goods like money and
wealth and honor and same physical
pleasure these have all been taken away
from you what's left you know your your
version your moral goodness that you
have does that still mean anything to
you is that bring you any sort of
happiness if not that all that
philosophy stuff that you were talking
about before was pretty much be a story
Diaz this is where the real test comes
in and she's not saying it quite so
straight Turkestan right see that she's
weaning him into it slowly but what
she's doing is providing you can think
of it as believe he is himself providing
a way that he could console himself for
the situation that he's now in using the
resources Audrey essentially Platonic
philosophy that had come to him here's
another interesting point he is a
Christian but there's nothing that no
mention of Christ in this book there's a
no Christian doctrine there's things
that are compatible with Christian
doctrine but they're not being taken
from Christianity they're being taken
from mostly platonic philosophy and a
few things from stoic philosophy as well
so you might say well what's going on
why wouldn't a Christian do that well
because you can you can also arrive at
the same conclusions in some cases
through certain schools of philosophy
and that that's what he ended up doing
it's interesting that a book that's not
about Christianity at all will be taken
by the monks and copied and commented on
and use so much because they saw certain
kindred spirits and when it comes down
to platonic philosophy was probably the
one that most of the early Christian
thinkers saw as most compatible with
Christianity Augustine's la la Justin
Martyr very early
Christian philosopher of that so one of
the other key themes you know there's an
investigation into what is the nature of
glitz and if you think about the stuff
that we desire and preoccupy ourselves
with we're still in the same situation
of allegiances there's certain basic
goods that we might sometimes add to but
they keep coming up over and over again
like well is money going to make us
happy money is good for self when you
don't have it it sure isn't fun
especially when you need it or even if
you go into debt but money isn't
sufficient to buy you happiness what
about Howard remember this is a guy who
actually did exercise he was second to
the king can that provide you with
happiness
what about fame we seek after this and
so the aspects of our life
we're honored or a prestige or you know
having the corner office or a title or
things like that and so bleakness goes
into I'm not going to sort of belabor
this but philosophy leads him into
thinking about well why do people want
these things because they think it's
going to make them happy you know even
pleasure physical pleasure you say what
are you on begging for so I can buy
stuff that's going to make me feel good
you know like going to Vegas right
you're just get a nice massage you have
steak and cigar you know free drinks at
the casino watch the wheels go around
and add whatever else you want right
those are all physical pleasures are
those actually going to make you feel
good we this is the answer ultimately
it's going to be no those aren't
happiness and whenever we pursue them
we're really putting ourselves at risk
because I mentioned that fortunes wheel
there's often goes down those are good
to fortune and if we pursue those we're
we're going to be unhappy because sooner
or later you lose them so what would be
even more durable
what could we actually hold on to it has
to be something internal who we are our
character and that's where he talks
about things like virtues this is a term
we don't use all that much these days so
you can substitute like moral goodness
or moral excellence what makes us good
people and we Thea said that eventually
he says could take a lot of convincing
of him that the good are camping even if
there didn't bad you know physical
circumstances or you know they don't
have a lot of their bank accounts or
people don't like them they are not only
happy but they're actually closer to God
the more that we become morally good the
more divine a few cents we become the
more we become like goodness itself and
likewise if they had people who seem to
have it pretty good quite often and get
away with all sorts of stuff they're not
really happy there's probably something
to this you look at a lot of people who
get away with things and give everyone a
chance to interact with them they're not
some of them are you know can't be in a
sense they're happy they go to jail and
you know they got away with spa or but
they're not fundamentally happy they're
not fulfilled
usually and so you know this leads into
a bigger deeper question which is well
let's say there is a good guy
that God actually cares about human
beings why the hell would that God let
the bad people get away with so much
stuff and screw themselves up and make
things bad for the good people or the
poor suckers of the cloudy between
percolated and I like that right this is
the question of what we call Providence
why why are things arranged the way they
are when we talk about something being
providentially arranged this means that
it would be arranged for some sort of
purpose there'd be some rationality
you know when people say oh gods
mysterious ways
that's not exactly what boëthius is
talking about it's not supposed to just
be a mystery it's supposed to in some
way make sense and so what we do is is
trying to do is provide an account that
makes sense
and here's ultimately the accountants
well with good people you know the
goodness that they have within the BATF
its own reward that is the happiness
that they have the bad people are
punished by having to be who they are by
having to live with themselves this
leads to one last question which it's
raised what thing you do except there is
the providential ordering of things I
mean that God would know ahead of time
how things are going to go now if you
say something like that
what kind of worries will you have about
your own self yeah the only wondering
what you you didn't you were good or bad
what happened to you and all is you
committing it at least that's how I look
at it yeah that wasn't where I was going
to go with that that's a good point I
would be sir he's like no different
possibilities that you never realized I
suppose or things that you he knows
ahead of time that if you go take a job
over there to be careful figure even if
you only know that after you going to
pick it up or you know it feels very
silly example from when I was a kid I
actually played on a thousand I took my
mom's keys and I shoved them into a
electrical socket thinking I was going
to start the car and boy and I learn
quick that you don't do that
presumably God or know ahead of that you
don't do that skirt the neck may dad but
that's it
it's not that although that's was a good
play if dad knows everything that's
getting happen ahead time weather means
you're good at your dad or any of those
sorts of things
very problem with the way that we
normally arises from we wouldn't have to
think about stopping your decision for
the chain trip don't think yeah so if
it's all fixed then what are we lacking
let me join you
yeah thanks but why bother to educate
why bother to even discuss them because
your your your have become state a
lipstick that yeah you're in your honor
so you don't have it yeah so we you
would be laughing free will to the inlet
and then your act is sort of failed us
to get a feel of you know God wanted me
to know the stuff that you know my
parents say I should know my teacher
says you know you could be able to give
it to me that's something like that ever
why you bother giving it to you it
doesn't matter what you did economy the
thing okay
so God could have just saved himself a
lot of trouble I had to start and just
not giving these people on these things
even if you were you know all-powerful I
think that would be terrible
you have some chances yeah yeah I mean
you know this is actually the bit of a
digression but one of the things that I
really like about some of the medieval
thinkers is they try to give you some
some reasonable understanding of what
like being in heaven would be like
because the way most people describe
heaven it sounds extremely boring place
you know that old picture like playing
harps and I like playing with Daniel for
about an hour and then I wanted it over
stop you know I can't imagine just
craving something for all eternity that
doesn't sound like a lot of fun for me
so some of great theologians have
actually like Saint Anselm for example
he discusses what would be going on and
it's not like well first there's this
you over here in this a little bit one
Ethan yeah
but you're right if it's just like the
same stuff over and over again and we
don't have any creative involvement
ourselves but why do it and so this is a
real problem
this is a fundamental worry that
ancients had and it continues through
the modern time if everything is really
fixed and in this case it would be fixed
because God sees it or arranges of ahead
of time then what what the hell are we
doing right this is what they call the
problem the problem of divine problem to
the divine foreknowledge and free will
and weaknesses treatment this and I'm
going to really simplify here so I'd
again I encourage you to get the book
and read it is really worth checking out
he pulls out that God doesn't see time
the way of leader and it leads to
something that in contemporary
philosophy called presence ISM about
time so you know like right now an hour
and 13 minutes have passed since I
started talking and you know we think
about a time right there's the time when
we all shop within here and now there's
going to be a time and we all leave and
right now we're in this part of the time
right we're moving through it and I
could choose things like I can at this
point say ah lectures done let's get the
hell out of here right that could happen
because I do have free will
now if God is sort of following along
with us but he just happens to like see
further than along that means we don't
really choose anything because he
already sees me choosing now let's stick
around and talk about the rest of the
lecture you know for the next however
long and answer the questions the full
circle thing and I'm already doing with
you says no God see the whole sweep all
of it is one present moment Ram it's not
like he has to wait to get to this point
if it's all present so there isn't any
for now which because there's any for
forgot that's the way we see things so
God knows you know from all eternity
whether I'm going to be a good person or
a bad person or go from being a good
person to a bad person or vice versa I
don't know it but the reason he knows it
is because I actually do have free will
and there's room for that in this grand
scheme in which God gets to sort of
observe what what's happening again this
is oversimplifying it that is full
position but that's the gist of it and
this is a big issue did you hear the
sort of thing you're like I don't quick
get that that's perfectly okay this is a
very deep metaphysical question that we
pious is is played so now it brings us
to a close and we'll do a little bit
more QA after this why the hell is he
talking about that in a book that's
supposed to be about consolation of
philosophy all of these things are about
philosophy is something that has to do
with our lives and gives gives our lives
on their deepest perspective you could
say the most people in his time don't
get access to philosophy we do
fortunately to deliver the Internet
occasion any book that we want to find
we can use we can access pretty much
yeah 99 cents Amazon Kindle oh yeah yeah
work well you can also find all free
versions other tip but I tend to prefer
yes free oh yeah and the idea is
absolutely required books and you know
that mean we've got with the reason
books we have to understand the but
philosophy working through these really
fundamental issues would provide a
consolation not because it like helps
you wile away the time so you don't
realize your prison cell is something
like that but because it puts everything
into perspective
now we could of course disagree rather
than say well you're wrong about this
you're running like that but in order to
do so we actually have to read them and
understand what he's saying or we're not
actually
disagreeing members disagree with the
loss on him and if we do that we risk
that we might be actually convinced by
chevre so I think that might explain
some degree this is something scholars
talk to us because scholars know way
more about the Middle Ages than I do and
what are way smarter than I why was this
book so popular I think that's part of
part of the answer there yeah when you
do read it it sort of sucks you in even
if you disagree with it you're going to
find yourself taking some of the things
seriously and there's even a sort of
joint account and again students who
have no interest whatsoever in reading
philosophy who you know scientists too
and they experience some of that joy so
I think that's a good thing to end on
and talking about previous or this time
yeah any any questions you've got or
comments I'm happy to entertain them
yeah I had a question today I was also
thinking it's about philosophy I got in
philosophy religion and philosophy yeah
when during Aristotle or Plato 10 how
much did did their philosophy did they
talk about God okay that's a great
question so you know there were the
ancient Greek gods right the sort of
Pantheon
and there was always kind of a mess we
present it as if it's like you know
there's 12 God and they each do their
separate thing but really the poets are
telling different stories about him of
the gods and sometimes you know fight
with each other or seduce each other in
the way in Plato didn't think and part
of this teacher thing that those stories
really curate a new way he thought that
they were probably you know the poets
making stuff up but he thought that
there were divine beings they just
wouldn't be doing that sort of stuff
like seduced into the sponsors right
that's not particularly gossiping
eventually people in point don't say
what you know Zeus gets to do that like
why can't I do it you know
oh yes is going to ask you if there is
there a diva there was a actually Plato
makes fun of this in a dialogue healthy
Euthyphro Euthyphro is this guy is
Kenneth pious and everyone's saying that
is impious because he is prosecuting his
father for a crime for having thrown a
slave who killed another slave into a
ditch till he got there the next day to
take care of him and then the slave died
so he's prosecuting his father and their
life you shouldn't be doing that he's
your father and you've the pros like
look juice you know took a action
against his father with so this is the
right thing for you so Plato's making
fun of that sort of thing and a first
Aristotle wasn't buying to that either
but they thought there was a divine and
they tend to identify that divine with
rationality with reason and they they
and also Stoics thought that the
rationality within us is in a certain
sense either part of the divine or or
likely divine you know it's it's mixed
in with a lot of other stuff in our
desires and stuff from the body but but
it really can orient us towards the
divine I may have different ways of
doing yet the Cure ian's where we're
different lot they thought there were
gods but they thought that the gods
didn't care anything about human beings
because if they did they would be as
screwed up as us and the gods are happy
the reason why they're happy they don't
mess with human because of all but and
so that you know you can see them moving
towards you might call it higher and
higher more purified understandings of
the divine right so when Christianity
comes on the scene also Judaism to do
this coming up um seen an encounter yes
it's not totally for that you know what
their what their engaging and in a
certain sense
Christianity by having
this on this guy Jesus of Nazareth it
was seen as less rational that you know
from the philosophers point of view
sometimes you know more peasant like
more superstitious but and what these
philosophers were offering now the later
philosophers were able to find ways to
synthesize these people of Alexandria
synthesizes platonic philosophy and the
Jewish Torah you know they're really
some of the early Christian philosophers
managed to finally as to synthesize it
they never synthesized epicurean
philosophy Epicureans are the bad guys
but platanus Aristotelian stoic
philosophy they often absorb a lot of
ideas from relative I was interested in
I guess when you're talking of it
summing up both this is like speeches
which it's like you your reward is that
you feel good and then a bad person
punishment that they're never going to
feel like happy and I thinking about
that in terms of like Buddhists Oh ideas
because that's similar I mean they say
like you don't you it's no you that
there's you know it's just it just the
focus is how do you not be suffering no
you're suffering in life but how do you
not be suffering and part of that is
just feeling happy but yeah I mean you
know in acting in a way that makes helps
others because it does benefit to your
well-being and recognizing you might say
higher values you know things beyond
just selfishness or momentary pleasures
or having some power over somebody on
yeah and you see this so that's
something that you see in a lot of
different wisdom traditions and some of
them are you know Greek philosophical
Buddhism you see that in Confucian and
Taoist traditions see that in you know
Western theological traditions a lot of
different people I don't want to say
reinventing the same room but you know
discovering the same basic principles
and doing something the number of
different starting points which is
pretty cool I think